have a look at this campaign that has
started on Twitter started by a man
called Jason Ross and he started this
crimen while white Twitter a hashtag
talked about his own instance 17 site of
a booze and caught with a gun at school
no one called me a thug can't recommend
being white highly enough and then he
went on and asked other people to appeal
foreign let's just have a quick look at
some of the others Cecily Kellogg said
at 13 I stole a car with my friends and
I drove it two weeks before we got
busted only one charged was black crimen
white what do you make of this Twitter
campaign I think the intention behind it
might have been a good one but I
personally found it a little bit cringy
some of it is comes across as being
quite bragging you know basically people
saying well look um it's in our life
great because we're white we can get
away with things and we must remember
this started around the issue of Eric
garner and I think if I was his family
how would I feel about people basically
boasting about what they can get away
with we know there are racial
disparities in crime and law enforcement
in America you know the statistics there
for everyone to see I personally didn't
find this particularly helpful yeah
another example here Aaron way as
meeting friends for campaign three-hour
drive black lawyer only one with no
criminal record only one pulled over
four times on the way I mean there has a
serious message behind us and these
things do happen yeah okay let's have a
look at some of the response to this and
I think we've got to Tschida somewhere
here here we go I can't even imagine
getting away with any of these scenarios
on this crime in wild white hashtag it's
like two different worlds and that is
the point isn't it and that Barack Obama
has been talking about that if we've got
inequality in law enforcement we've got
a big problem yeah it is two different
worlds but I find it interesting that
this is surprising I mean we know
American history we know where America
is and isn't the one of the reasons why
people so upset is because Eric garner
was a black man who was killed by white
officer and you know there's a there's a
difference in how black men treated
under the law and by law enforcement yes
if the feeling is that there are two
justice systems criminal justice systems
one for white people and wasn't yet
people I recent events in Ferguson and
by today's decision York as well let's
have a look at some more of these then
ceska franchesca ramsey says I just hope
people contributing to crime in
worldwide a vocal about these
disparities offline great you're
trending but we need action I mean you
say it's not a surprise but there are
people on here reflecting that actually
they're really shocked that this could
be going on um that shocks me that
they're shocked I mean I think that if
we I know I mean even in London recently
walking around in a major shopping mall
I won't say which it was but I was
followed around you know i think i would
think or maybe this is my assumption
maybe it's wrong that for a lot of black
people we know that you know we're
treated differently we know that if a
police officer stops us even if it's in
England we're not even just in America
that we should act differently I think
what it is is people being so feeling so
okay with saying I committed a crime and
I got away with it I think that's what's
the shop yeah that's exactly the point
that your Landers making here white
privilege is confessing criminality on
The Chronicle white hashtag without any
fear of reprisal let that sink in
exactly your point isn't yeah I think it
Lola thank you very much thank you